The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHRIS: All right, so
we'll get started again.
And as I said, we're
going to provide you
with a quick tour of both some
basic concepts in recording
audio, as well as the
specifics of our audio package.
And then we're hoping that we
have about an hour at the end
to play with both the camera and
the audio equipment together.
So this is a very,
very cursory look
at some basic audio concepts.
And there are a couple of
really, really simple-sounding
rules that I want to emphasize.
And this is the first one.
Sometimes sound is more
important than picture.
And someone like
Vertov would probably
have a heart attack if he
heard someone involved in film
say that.
Because of course,
the Kino-Eye is God.
But this is actually true.
And if you think
about it, if you
got the interview of a lifetime
or got to spend half an hour
filming someone who
you just were never
going to be able to
film again and you had
a choice between
getting the audio
and the video, which
would you pick?
AUDIENCE: Audio.
Because s
CHRIS: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Audio.
CHRIS: Yeah.
Because if you don't have--
I mean, of course, it depends.
If you're filming the
labor in the field
and you're not talking
about specific individuals,
if you're talking about
vast social groups,
then the image,
of course, is all.
And image is
extraordinarily important.
I'm not, of course,
diminishing that.
But if you get to spend
15 minutes or five minutes
asking Barack Obama
what he thinks
about topic X of
your documentary
and you don't have any
audio, that was that.
If you don't have any picture,
you can still use the audio,
and you can find a
way to make it work.
So audio is extremely important.
And the only reason
I'm emphasizing that
is that it sometimes
gets short shrift when
people are thinking
about film or they're
learning to make films.
There's sort of an
assumption that it
can take care of itself, that
I'm going to get familiar
with the camera and
it's digital audio,
it's really great
quality, it'll be fine.
It's its own art form.
And it is complex.
And it's definitely
worth knowing the basics.
So this is just a quick
look at our equipment
we are filming with the Sony
A1U HDV camcorder, which
records digital audio
at a sample rate of 48K
and a bit depth of
16, or 16-bit audio.
And we're going to talk
a little bit about what
that means in a minute.
But for now, it's worth
just noting and remembering
that that is the format
that you're recording in.
It becomes very
important when you're
editing in post-production
to know what
the format of your audio is.
And that's it.
We can film to two channels,
left and right, which
means that you
can record stereo,
or you can use them
as separate tracks
with two microphones recording
completely different things.
So two channels
does not necessarily
mean that it's
automatically stereo.
It depends on how you set it up.
We have two microphones
in our kits.
One is a lavalier
microphone, which
is like the one
I'm wearing here,
something you can
clip to a person.
Ours are not wireless,
unfortunately,
like the one I'm
wearing right now.
They are omnidirectional
microphones.
And we'll talk in a minute
about what that means.
We have one shotgun
microphone, which is a longer,
larger, thinner microphone.
You'll see it in a minute.
And that is what we call a
supercardioid microphone.
And again, we'll talk
about that in a minute.
So what does
omnidirectional mean?
As I said, our lavalier
are omnidirectional mics.
What that means is that their
pattern, the pattern of pickup,
the pattern that they
record, goes out equally
in all directions.
So if you see in this
picture, the microphone
head there is in the
center of the frame.
Everything equally
in all directions
is recorded at a similar level.
So if you're two feet away
to the left and two feet away
to the right and two feet
above and two feet below,
it's all the same.
So you can move further away
from the microphone and closer.
But changing the orientation
of the microphone
is not going to
change your recording.
So again, it's a great
microphone to put on a person.
Not all lavalier microphones
are omnidirectional, by the way,
but ours are.
And it's kind of a set it
and forget it kind of mic.
You put it there.
You set it down.
And it records what's around
it based on how far away
and how loud the noise is.
Now, the disadvantage of an
omnidirectional microphone
is that it picks up everything.
So if I'm here talking to
you with an omnidirectional
microphone on and there's a car
or a truck idling over here,
the microphone is
going to pick up
that sound equally to the
sound that I'm making here.
It doesn't distinguish.
It's just whatever is in
my field, I'm recording.
And that's why we have
other patterns that we
use in other situations.
The boom-- the boom microphone--
is a supercardioid pattern.
And you can see that's a
very different pattern.
It's primarily focused to
the front of the microphone.
So you're going
to record what you
point at much more strongly
than anything to the side.
You see how it drops off
on the left and the right,
and then there's a little bit
of pickup in the back, as well?
But it's much narrower
and not as intense.
So this is really
great for a situation
where you have a lot
of external noise.
So if you were
interviewing somebody
and there's a truck idling just
to the left or to the right,
if you point the
microphone right at them
and get a very good
read on their mouth
and you're close enough, you
can actually really, really
significantly
reduce the recording
of the truck that's idling.
So as you can see, especially
in documentary film,
this is a really important
microphone to have.
Because you can't always control
the situation that you're
recording your audio in.
So in a really great audio
recording situation where
the room is pretty quiet--
this is not a bad room--
an omnidirectional can
solve a lot of problems
because you don't have
to worry about it,
and you don't have to have
somebody actually operating
the microphone or the boom.
But in a difficult
situation or a situation
that's very fluid, where
people are moving around,
this can really save you.
The downside, of
course, is that you
have to keep the
microphone pointed at what
you're trying to record.
And that means that you
need somebody doing that.
It's very hard for you--
well, really impossible--
for you as a cameraperson
to also be a boom operator.
Because that takes two
hands, and you're going to--
and it takes two brains.
And it's a completely
different thought process.
So this really
requires, especially
in a situation where maybe
somebody's moving around a lot
or you're going from one
thing to another, to have
a separate person
worrying about the audio,
worrying about the recording,
what the microphone's picking
up, listening very carefully.
So it's a really great
thing to have in your kit,
but it adds to the
complexity of shooting.
And you'll see that in a minute
when we pull out the equipment.
So what's the objective?
Simply put, get the
cleanest recording you
can at the best level you can.
The cleanest recording
means the one
that is the most focused on
the audio you want to record.
Dennis in the back
is recording me.
He wants to get a clean
level of my voice.
It sounds simple, but it
can get extremely difficult
and extremely complicated in a--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: No, I was just
pointing because there's
lots of sound [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: Oh, yeah.
So I don't know.
Dennis, I'm sure, is
getting a good level
because the microphone's
right by me,
and that is dropping away.
But absolutely.
If I decided to climb up
next to the air ducts,
Dennis would not be happy.
DENNIS: Or if I turn up the
camera mic to hear a question.
CHRIS: Exactly.
Right.
So he's got a microphone
mounted on the camera, which
he can use--
he can turn up to
record you guys.
But he is also, then, starting
to record the room sound.
So get the cleanest
recording you can
at the best level you can.
And we're going to talk a little
bit about recording levels
and what are good recording
levels here in a minute.
So how do you do that?
Well, there are a lot of
things you can change.
Again, if you go back
to the first class, when
we talk about what
we were calling
the plastic elements of film,
sound is one of those elements.
And within sound, there are
an infinite number of things
you can affect, you can
impact, you can change,
in order to improve the
audio that you record.
First, of course, is the
microphone you choose.
In our case, we have two.
We have the
omnidirectional lavalier,
which is going to be
exactly the right mic
in a lot of situations.
We have the
supercardioid boom, which
will be the right mic
for other situations.
The position of the microphone.
How close is it to your subject?
The lavalier I'm wearing right
now is really close to me.
It's really close to my mouth.
So it's picking up
a really good level.
Maybe it could be too good.
What if it's overmodulating?
What if I'm distorting
because I'm too loud?
Well, Dennis will hopefully
change that at the camera.
But another way
to change it would
be to move the microphone back.
So if you're booming,
for instance,
and someone was booming
me with a microphone
and I started yelling, you
could pull the microphone away,
and that would change the level.
You could obviously
change the position
and affect who you record.
If we were having a
conversation in this class
and someone was booming
the whole class,
they could focus
on me when I talk.
Then they could shift
to Dave when he talks,
shift to one of
you when you talk.
And you're changing,
of course, the level
of each of those things.
So what else can you change?
The location.
Sometimes you can change that.
So what I mean by that is let's
say you arrange that interview
with Barack Obama.
And it happens to be the day
that they're redoing the Rose
Garden, and there are
jackhammers and dumpsters
in the Rose Garden.
Well, what can
you do about that?
Maybe you can
change the location
to the other side
of the White House.
Maybe you can't.
But you can try,
and you should try.
If you find yourself
in a situation
where the audio recording
is just undoable,
you need to be proactive about
it and try to make a change.
And sometimes there's a
feeling of, oh, my gosh,
I can't do anything about this.
I can't bother this
person to change,
to change to a different
office or change the location.
But sometimes you have to force
yourself to speak up and do it.
So what else can you change?
The recording level
on the camera.
The cameras have adjustable
input recording levels
so that, depending on where
the microphone is placed,
how loud the sound is,
how loud the person is
or whatever it is
you're recording,
you can adjust the signal
that comes into the camera.
You can add a filter.
But you should be
careful about that.
The microphones and, I
believe, the camera, as well,
both have filters that
allow you to filter out
certain frequencies.
And I think they're
pretty much in all cases
low cut frequencies.
So they're designed to
filter out truck sounds.
Like if there's a truck idling
that's a very low-frequency
sound, it will cut it.
The reason you should be
careful is that, again,
once you've recorded it that
way, it's recorded that way.
You've lost those frequencies.
And it's generally better to do
that in post-production, to do
that in editing, where
you have control.
You have the full range
of your recording,
and then you can fix it later.
But in some cases, some really
significantly bad cases,
you may want to
use those filters.
And then, of course,
finally, your own technique.
You can do a better job
of placing the microphone,
do a better job of choosing
the microphone, and so on.
So digital audio-- what is it?
As I said, we have a sample rate
of 48K and a bit depth of 16.
And that is sometimes--
less so now as CDs
disappear from the scene--
but referred to as
CD-quality audio--
actually, slightly better.
What that means, however,
is not that your audio
will be pristine.
Because it all depends
on the recording.
It doesn't necessarily depend
on the technical quality
of your signal.
So in other words, you can
get pristine CD-quality audio
of that truck idling
next to your person,
and it still sucks.
And that's something that
you run into a lot of times.
When people are
starting out, they say,
but the audio is digital,
and it's very high quality.
It's going to be great.
I don't really need
to worry about it.
Again, it all
depends on what you
put in front of the microphone,
just like it depends on what
you put in front of the camera.
So I want to just mention
quickly what the sample rate is
and what the bit depth is.
Sound, most of us, I'm
sure, know sounds are waves.
They are waves of compressed
air that travel through the air.
And how much
compression there is
and how fast they are,
how short the wave is,
is what determines the loudness
and the frequency of the sound.
So if you think about,
well, how would you
translate that into
digital terms, what you do
is take a sample.
And the number of
samples per second
is what the sample rate is.
So this wave is broken down
into lots of little slices.
And the more slices you
have, the more smooth
this plot is going to be.
So slice, slice, slice, slice,
slice, or a lot fewer slices.
There would be a lot of
jagged edges up here.
So higher numbers are better.
That's kind of a very
simple way to look at it.
48K is very good sample rate.
CDs are 44.1.
48 is pretty much at the
level where human ears are not
going to hear any kind of
digitalness in the audio.
So that's the sample rate.
What's the bit depth?
So the bit depth is the
opposite side of the grid.
That's the number of bits
recorded in each sample.
So if you think about
it, this is our sample,
if we had vertical
lines going here.
The bit depth is the other side.
It's the horizontal
lines going up.
So if you have 16
bits, what that means
is there are 16
levels in each sample.
And if we had the
vertical lines here,
you would then suddenly see
that each one of these is a bit.
Each little box is a bit.
So again, higher
numbers are better
because you're slicing
it much more this way
and slicing it this way.
So the more you slice
it, the more you
end up with a very smooth path.
You see here we have this
digital, blocky path.
But it's emulating this very
smooth wave of the sound.
So 16-bit audio is, again,
a very, very high quality.
24-bit audio is, at this
point, what they generally
use to record professionally
if you're mastering
music or something like that.
But 16-bit is
extremely high quality.
So digital levels.
And this is-- you can
actually forget everything
that I just said to you.
I think it's worth knowing,
but it's not necessarily
anything you really
need to think about
on a day-to-day
basis when you're
recording audio for video.
But it's just nice to
know when somebody says,
oh, that's 48K audio, you know
what they're talking about.
This, however, is really, really
crucial in recording audio.
And this is a digital meter.
And it's what you really have to
live by when you're recording.
And Dave will show
you in a minute
how to see the
meter on the camera.
You have, basically,
in digital meters,
there's generally
a readout of dB--
decibels-- from minus 30 to 0.
And 0, if some of
you who know anything
about analog recording, 0 is
kind of a really good place
to be in analog recording.
It's a really bad place to
be in digital recording.
What you want to be--
you want your average level
to be between minus 20
and minus 12 and your peaks
around minus 10, at most
around minus 6.
Because, basically,
when you get to zero,
that's when you start
getting distortion.
That's the top end of
what can be recorded.
And after that, it's all gone.
And you're just
distorting your signal.
So you don't want to
get too close to zero.
And similarly, if you start
getting below minus 20,
your signal is so low
that the background
is going to start coming up.
And there's very
little difference
between what you're
actually trying to record
and what the background is.
So the key is really to stay
between minus 20 and minus 12.
But peaking a little higher
than that is totally fine.
By peaking, I mean I'm
talking very softly,
and then I say, (LOUDLY)
Dave, where's the camera?
So when I peak,
when I speak louder,
that would be fine to be
going up towards minus 6.
I don't know where
I went there, Dave.
Dennis, sorry.
[CHUCKLES] So anyway, this
is one of the crucial things
to remember, far more than the
bitrate or the sample rate.
And this is the second rule.
If it sounds bad,
it probably is bad.
And what I mean by
that is that far
beyond the microphones
or the cables
or the camera or the
filters or anything
you can do in post-production,
the most important tool
you have when you're
recording audio are your ears.
Your ears are really incredible.
You just have to learn how
to listen and to trust them.
So if you're hearing bad
sound in the headphones,
if you're hearing a
lot of interference
or a lot of background
noise, pay attention to that.
Don't just kind of
accept it like, oh, yeah,
I hear what's going on.
Listen to what else is
going on and then work
on trying to fix it,
either by, as I said,
you can change the microphone
or change the location,
change the position
of the microphone.
Try to solve your problems.
But your ears are what
are going to tell you
that you have a problem.
So if it sounds bad,
it probably is bad.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Just one example
that if it sounds bad,
it probably is.
One of the [INAUDIBLE] just
made that they helped out with,
which was about the Three
Mile Island nuclear plant,
and we had a lot of interviews
with people in their kitchens.
And one of the things that came
up was the refrigerator hum.
And you feel horrible.
I mean, it's this
documentary situation.
And you're talking to people.
But you keep hearing
this refrigerator
hum in the background.
And you don't want these
people to turn off the fridge.
But on the other hand,
if you don't do it,
then you have this buzz
throughout the recording
that you end up can't
using it afterwards.
So we had to become
bold about asking people
and, very apologetically,
look, if you don't mind,
can we just turn off your
fridge for a little bit?
Because we couldn't
get the sound otherwise
So those are the kind of
examples of things where,
even if you might feel
very awkward about it,
sometimes you have to do it.
Because people will be more--
they might be a little taken
aback, but they're going to be
far more irritated if they give
you two hours of their
lives for an interview,
and then all of it's
unusable because you
didn't get the sound right.
So those are the
instances where you
have to be bold,
even if you might be
feeling somewhat shy about it.
But again, listening to
your ears and trusting it.
And sometimes, you just have to
like, well, I'm not getting it.
We've got to do something else.
Or if there's airplane
noise overhead,
sometimes you're just losing it.
And you have to acknowledge that
and not think like, oh, it's
going to be a [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: And one thing, as Dave
goes through the audio package,
to remember is that there
are headphone volume--
there's a headphone volume
control on the camera.
But that's not the same as
the audio recording volume.
So sometimes what people do
is the sound is very faint,
or there's a problem.
They turn up the
headphone volume.
And they go, OK,
that's much better.
But it's not necessarily
better at all.
You have to look at the
level that is being recorded.
And you have to get the
headphone volume to the point
where you can actually
hear what you're recording
and assess it and see
if there's a problem.
So with that, I guess we'll
break out an audio kit.
DAVE: If you guys could
just open up the camera kit
and take out the cameras.
And put the battery
in the camera.
And turn that sucker on.
And again, there
are three options.
Make sure that
the green light is
at the very top
where it says Tape
when you're turning the knob.
Again, green light at the
very top where it says Tape.
AUDIENCE: (WHISPERING) You
might already know this stuff.
DAVE: Cool.
Everybody there?
Excellent.
If you could, inside
of your camera kits,
we have the audio
adapter, the XLR adapter
for higher-quality sound.
If you could take this piece
out of the camera kit, please--
this piece.
AUDIENCE: Do you want
me to take this out?
DAVE: Very good.
Oh, are we taping
this or using tape?
CHRIS: We don't-- well--
DAVE: I mean, it's-- you
don't-- it doesn't really--
CHRIS: We don't really
need to tape at this point.
DAVE: No, just to hear.
CHRIS: We'll talk
about-- there's
an exercise, a little exercise,
between now and next week.
And we'll have some tape out
for that at the very end.
But yeah.
DAVE: Cool.
Now, if you guys will
notice, on the bottom
of this little adapter,
you have a little
like a branch with a knob on it.
If you guys could fit that
to the top of the camera
where you see that little
metal plate with the arrow.
Just make sure you slide
it in the same direction
that the arrow is telling
you to slide it into.
And I'm sorry.
This little extension
here, the little tail,
that's going to be going
toward you on the camera.
So make sure it's
facing this direction.
CHRIS: Your bag's in
the way for the shot.
DAVE: Oh, sorry.
Once you have that--
oh, actually, this one
is already tightened.
If it's not sliding
in, turn the knob.
Once it is on there, make
sure you turn the knob again
to tighten it.
You don't want this
sliding off the camera.
So again, once it's slid on,
this little knob right here,
make sure it's as
tight as it can be.
Cool.
Now, once that's slid on
and you have it tightened,
open up this little hatch right
here on the top of the camera,
right behind the adapter.
And take this little chute
right here and just slide it in.
Again, use the arrow
that's on the bottom of it,
and match it up with
the arrow that's
in the little hatch door.
So again, the arrow
that's on the bottom,
match it up with the arrow
that's within the actual door
there.
And when it's in,
slide it forward
until you feel it click.
This is the actual
connection to the camera.
So if this is not
inserted correctly
and you don't hear
it click, then you're
not going to be
recording any sound,
at least from these
microphones that you're
using the adapter for.
Everybody good?
Again, make sure this
is tight, please.
Cool.
Now, before we actually
connect the mics,
on the left-hand
side of this adapter,
you'll see a number of switches.
It's very important that you
turn the switches on correctly.
We're going to use the lab mic,
as well, two separate channels?
CHRIS: Yeah, I think we should
go through everything, yeah.
DAVE: OK.
The one at the very front,
where it says recording channel
select, if you're going to
go with just one microphone,
make sure it's on-- it's
kind of counterintuitive--
if you're using
just one microphone,
make sure that the switch is
on channel 1 and channel 2.
Because what it's going to do is
if you're using one microphone,
it's going to route it
to both those channels.
So you have the option of
stereo when you import it.
If you're using two microphones,
two separate channels,
make sure this switch right
here is switched to channel 1.
It's counterintuitive, I know.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat that?
DAVE: If you're using
two separate microphones,
make sure this front
switch is on channel 1.
Because what it's
going to do is it's
going to make sure that that
first microphone is routed
to channel 1 instead
of both channels
so that you will actually
have a free channel
for your second microphone.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the same one?
Or when I [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE: Yeah.
There are two jacks.
And you're going to have
two separate lines for two
separate mics.
What you're holding
right there--
actually, if you want to
get a shot of this, Dennis.
Can I use your name on camera?
I just want to--
this one right here does
not have a battery in it,
the one that's
included in the kit.
So if, for any
reason, you decide
to use this microphone that's
included in the camera kit,
make sure that the plus 48
volts is switched to on.
You only put that on on if
your microphone does not
have a battery.
That way, the electricity will
run through the camera battery.
But the good mics
that we're going
to use in the audio packet, they
should have batteries in there
that you actually put
into the microphone.
If you put plus 48
volts and you have
a battery in your
microphone, you're
going to have some
pretty loud sound.
CHRIS: A lot of distortion.
DAVE: A lot of distortion, yeah.
CHRIS: So this was a big issue
last time we taught this class.
So again, if you're going
to use the microphones
in the audio kit,
switch that to off.
And just make sure that you have
batteries in your microphones,
as well.
We'll get to that in a minute.
DAVE: Which, again,
when you actually
have your headphones connected
and you see the levels,
you're going to be able
to check that, anyway.
For your input
level, you see where,
on the actual left side
of the audio adapter,
it's divided into two
sections, input 1 and input 2?
For both input 1 and input
2, where it says input level,
make sure you have the middle
selection, which says mic.
So for input 1, make
sure that's set to mic.
For input 2, where
it says input level,
make sure that's
set to mic, as well.
That's just telling your adapter
that you're using a microphone.
The only reason you
really set it to line,
which is the top option,
is if you're using a mixer
or if you're going through
some outside source.
A mixer allows you to have
more than two channels,
and you can actually control
the volume and stuff like that.
We don't have a mixer.
If you have one at home,
propping up your coffee table
or something, you can
bring that in and use that.
So it's very important that you
have input level set to mic.
If you have the very
bottom one, mic attenuated,
that's going to cut
out some of your sound.
So don't set it to that.
Set it to the middle one, mic.
Again-- we kind of went
over this already--
for both input 1 and input 2,
where it says plus 48 volts,
make sure that's set to off
for both input 1 and input 2.
Do you want me to point to it?
CHRIS: I've got it in
the shot right now.
DAVE: OK, cool.
On the back of the
adapter, you'll
see there are two
low cut filters.
These are for both mics.
Make sure these are set to off.
Because, again, what
low cut filters do
is they cut out that deeper,
the deeper frequencies.
And you probably
don't want to do that,
especially in an interview.
Because the human voice,
you need that to--
it's going to sound very
thin if you have that on.
So make sure that, again,
the low cut filters
are both set to off on the
very back of the audio adapter.
And again, like Chris was
saying, if you do need to--
say you want to simulate a
telephone call or a telephone
conversation, that's
something you can do in post.
You just take out the low
frequency and the high,
and you just boost the middle.
You can do something
like that in post.
You want to get as much of
a dynamic range as possible
when you're in the
field, recording stuff.
OK, everybody there?
All right.
Now, if you guys could
break out those sound bags,
the sound kits.
Yeah, I'll put this here.
The first thing we will do is
go over the shotgun microphone.
This is a supercardioid
microphone.
So if everybody could-- it
should be buried in almost all
the packets--
I think all of them-- in the
front of the two big pockets.
[CHATTER]
OK, everybody got it?
If you could, at the very
back, if you twist the back,
it should twist open.
Make sure there is a AA
battery inside the microphone.
If there isn't, let me know.
And then you can
twist it shut again.
Now, with the
shotgun microphones,
there are two covers.
There is the black
one, which is mostly
used for indoor shooting.
If you're outside and there's
street noise and stuff
like that, you would use the--
actually, I have one of my
kit, Mr. Snuffleupagus here.
This is for, again--
oh, my tag fell off--
if you're in an
outdoor situation
where there's a lot of street
noise or ambient noise.
You're probably better,
especially for wind,
you're better using this cover
rather than the black one.
Again, use this one
for indoor shooting,
the one that's already on
the shotgun microphone.
Very few situations where
I would go with no cover.
Even in a room like this
or in an indoor setting
you probably want to
have this black cover on.
AUDIENCE: Which [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVE: This one right here.
This is for outdoor shooting
circumstances or situations.
It's just heavier,
and it muffles,
or it blocks out,
the sound a lot
easier than this one right here.
So again, if you're
outside, and there's
a lot of ambient
street noise or wind,
even a slight wind,
go with this one--
slight breeze.
Next, pull out this little
doohickey, the shock mount.
This is what you're going
to use to hold your shotgun
microphone.
And if you notice on the
bottom, right here, there's
also a place to screw it in.
And you're going to screw it in,
eventually, to your boom pole.
But for now, if you could,
in the front of your kit--
some of the bags are a little
different than others--
one of those front
pockets in the kit,
you should have two
rubber suspenders.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Should we
use the [INAUDIBLE]??
DAVE: Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I had to
give you a new kit.
If you just open that up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE: Yeah.
These are what
you're going to use
to hold the shotgun mic in
place in this shock mount.
So what I would do first is--
actually, you're going to put
the suspenders on either end.
So you're going to have--
this is going to
be pretty loose,
even with these elastic bands.
So you're going to want to
put one of these right here
and one of them here.
They're a little
hard to slide on.
So it may take
you a little time.
But if you put your shotgun
mic through the actual shock
mount like this, in the middle,
and then use the suspenders
to hold it in place.
Do you think we're
going to need to--
I'm not even going to bother.
These are such a
pain to get off.
CHRIS: What, the shock mounts?
DAVE: Yeah.
CHRIS: I often don't use them.
If you have tape,
that's cool, too.
But these are
included with the kit.
AUDIENCE: So we put one here?
DAVE: OK, in these
little bags here,
you will find your boom poles.
If you guys could open those up
and take out your boom poles.
At the tip of your
boom pole, you
will notice there is a screw.
That's going to screw into the
bottom of your shock mounts.
These are, by the way,
extendable and retractable,
obviously.
So you can, if you turn
the little knob here,
you can loosen it
and extend the pull
if you need a little
more distance.
Or you can just
keep it where it is.
Actually, is this the new one?
It is, OK.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
is this supposed to--
DAVE: Oh, yeah, yeah.
You can take that
off if you like.
AUDIENCE: I guess you don't
need that [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE: No.
You can take it off.
CHRIS: So my suggestion is you
[INAUDIBLE] his office hours
tomorrow.
DAVE: Once you have the--
CHRIS: So that could be Monday.
AUDIENCE: Monday?
CHRIS: Yeah.
So the idea probably would
be for you [INAUDIBLE]..
[CLATTERS]
DAVE: Once you have-- oh, good--
some of you are already there.
Just screw your shock mount
onto the tip of your boom pole.
And if you want, just practice
extending it, retracting it.
Hold it like this.
It's good to have sort
of a branch with this.
If you're working the boom
pole, you can go like this
and actually hold
it over your head.
But it's very uncomfortable
after a certain amount of time.
So what you could do is
try to keep your elbow
in toward your
body, and use this
as the hand which
turns your microphone,
while this is just
there to hold it up.
CHRIS: And you can either--
AUDIENCE: How do you extend it?
What do you do it?
DAVE: You just turn the
knob here to loosen it.
And then this should
pull right up.
There you go.
[CHATTER]
All right, now that you
have your boom pole set
up with your shock mount and
your shotgun microphone, inside
of your camera kits, you
should find two XLR cables.
If you could grab one of
them for now, one of the two
XLR cables in your audio package
bag-- not in your camera kit
but in your audio bag.
There should be two
cables like these.
Grab one of them.
And just unroll it.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to connect one end
to the back of your shotgun
microphone and the other end
into the audio adapter, input
1.
I think a general rule--
Dennis, I don't know if you
agree with this-- general rule
is try to keep your shotgun
on input 1 and any other mic
in input 2, if you're
going to use a second mic.
So again, one end into the
back of the shotgun microphone
that's already hooked
up to the shock
mount, the other end into
input 1 on your audio adapter
on your camera.
CHRIS: No.
For now, we're assigning teams.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: Very nice.
Yeah, basically, the homework
is going to be [INAUDIBLE]..
And we're going to
have [INAUDIBLE]..
So then we're gonna
assign groups [INAUDIBLE]..
Ultimately, people will come
together in whatever team
they want.
But for this first
time, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Because
I have my own camera if you
want to just [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: Yeah, well, you're always
going to have your partner
to help you.
But [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Input.
DAVE: Input 1.
Make sure it clicks,
both on the shotgun mic
and when you plug it
into your audio adapter.
Make sure you hear that click.
CHRIS: --more than one shot
[INAUDIBLE] put this together.
[INAUDIBLE]
DAVE: All right, once everybody
has their shotgun mic connected
to their camera, if you
could, go to the P menu
on your LCD screen, your P menu.
And all the cameras should have
as the second and third options
audio channel 1 level and
audio channel 2 level.
DENNIS: Can you find
your [INAUDIBLE]??
DAVE: Like that?
DENNIS: Yep.
DAVE: OK.
If you click on audio channel
level, or audio channel 1
level, you will see that you
can set your audio level here.
I would set this with the
plus button to about 3/4
of the way up on the
little bar meter.
Again, you can change
this if necessary,
depending on your
shooting situation.
AUDIENCE: What would
be the [INAUDIBLE]
for setting it to auto?
DAVE: That's if you're not going
to be able to man the camera.
And what it does is it just
picks the loudest noise
and modulates it automatically.
[CHATTER]
Now, in the top left-hand
corner of your LCD screen,
that's where you can
monitor your levels.
So since you have your shotgun
mic already plugged in,
you should maybe work as a team.
Have one person-- and maybe
switch off the camera so both
people in the team can see--
but have one person
speak into the microphone
and play around, and have the
other person watch the screen.
So again, in the top left-hand
corner of the LCD screen,
you'll see channel
1 and channel 2.
Again, practice talking
into the microphone,
moving it away from your face,
toward your face, maybe other
places in the room.
And just watch that level
meter in your top left-hand
of your LCD screen.
You should be getting levels.
You should see that
go up and down.
Typically, what
you want to do is
you want to keep that about
3/4 of the way up, on average.
Because once you start getting
to the top of that bar,
that's where you're going to
start hearing some crackling.
And that's where you're going
to get noise that is just lost.
So try to keep that bar at
about 3/4 of the way up.
If you need to adjust
your volume level,
again, go back to the P menu,
and go to the channel 1 level.
And you can adjust it there
with the plus or minus buttons.
Or if you're a
boom mic operator,
like Chris was saying
earlier in class,
you could just move the mic
further away or closer to.
AUDIENCE: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So what are we-- are we
looking for that stays kind
of in the middle of the--
DAVE: I would, on average,
about 3/4 of the way up the bar.
Try to keep it around there.
[CHATTER]
AUDIENCE: So you want it to
be-- the maximum would be
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you want
it beginning with the 20.
DAVE: Is everybody
comfortable with the booms?
I'll give you a few minutes.
[CHATTER]
Again, obviously,
with the boom mics,
try to aim toward the
mouth, maybe at an angle.
I always aim for the
nose, the tip of the nose.
Some people, they
had the channel level
set to channel 1 and 2.
And on the top left-hand
side of your LCD panel,
you're getting different levels.
You still have to
change the audio levels
within your P menu for both
channel 1 and channel 2.
If you want them
to even out, you
have to make sure that the
levels on channel 1 and channel
2 are set to the
exact same levels.
I know it's kind of confusing.
Since we're going to
be using two mics, two
separate channels,
make sure, again,
that that audio input
is set to channel 1.
The recording channel
select, make sure
that's set to channel 1 instead
of channel 1 and channel 2.
AUDIENCE: So when do we use
channel 1 and channel 2?
DAVE: If you only
have one microphone
and you want to make sure that
it records in two channels--
AUDIENCE: OK, what's
the difference
between recording one
microphone and one channel
and one microphone
and two channels?
CHRIS: You can set
the levels separately.
DAVE: One microphone in the
channel 1 and channel 2?
People usually do
that if they want
to set, say, the
volume to have it
record from one microphone
with two separate volumes.
So they don't want to, say,
overmodulate or overrecord.
So they'll set channel 1 in the
P menu to say, 3/4, of the way
up.
And they might set channel
2, the audio level,
to maybe halfway up the bar.
AUDIENCE: Is it something
you would do, worth doing?
You do it just in case
you get one of them wrong?
Or do you do--
DAVE: Yeah, I mean, it's
basically to protect yourself
when you're importing
the audio files.
But again, if you want both--
if you're only recording
with one external microphone
and you want your audio
levels to be the same,
you would have to make sure that
those green bars inside the P
menu, both channel 1 and channel
2, are at the same place.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
[CHATTER]
CHRIS: Not necessarily.
It depends.
You can use both.
DAVE: We're going to go with
the second mic right now.
Yeah, it's a little confusing.
If you want-- again, if you're
only using one microphone
and you want both
these top meters
to hit the exact
same place, you have
to make sure that when
you go into P menu,
the levels for channel
1 and channel 2
are both the same place.
So for instance, if
you click on channel 1,
you see those green bars
go up to this point.
You want to make sure that
the green bars in channel 2
go up to the same level.
If you want to
keep both channel 1
and channel 2 on the top
left-hand side of your screen,
if you want to keep
them both uniform,
you have to adjust both channel
1 and channel 2 in your P menu.
This is kind of confusing.
AUDIENCE: Wait, it's a choice.
AUDIENCE: So it's like
if someone [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS: Exactly, yeah.
I mean, that's sort of a
professional audio trick.
A lot of audio
recordists, if they're
in a situation
that's kind of fluid
and they don't know
what's going to happen,
and they're recording
one line to two channels,
there might be a second
channel slightly lower.
So that way, you can
"bail out to that,"
quote, unquote, if the
first channel is distorted.
But a simpler way to think about
it is just having [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE: Does anybody have any
questions about choosing
channel 1 and channel 2
versus channel 1-- bless you--
and the levels that
you're recording at,
the top left-hand
side of the LCD?
Anybody have any
questions about that?
AUDIENCE: Does any channel
the preferential channel?
Because it only lets you set--
DAVE: Channel 1 is
the preferential.
If you only have one
microphone, go with channel 1.
And if you're going with
two different kind of mics,
like, say, a boom
mic and a lavalier,
I would always route the
boom mic to channel 1.
Because people in
post, they usually
know that channel 1 is the boom.
AUDIENCE: That's [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE: Yeah, just so in post
you know which mic was which,
so when you're editing.
[CHATTER]
AUDIENCE: We should have
two microphones connected,
but it's on channel 1,
channel 2 [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE: Sure.
If You have two
microphones connected,
and they're channel
1, channel 2,
it will only take the first mic.
So that's a good point.
[? Anahita ?]
raised a good point.
If you have two
microphones plugged in
and your recording channel is
set to channel 1 and channel 2,
it will just record
the first microphone.
So you may as well not have
plugged in the second mic
at all.
AUDIENCE: Will it assign
which one that is?
DAVE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Will it assign by
itself which one [INAUDIBLE]??
DAVE: Yeah.
When you put it to channel 1 and
channel 2 rather than channel
1, it automatically assumes
that you're going with one mic.
CHRIS: And whatever is
plugged into channel 1
is all you're going to get.
DAVE: Yeah.
So you're not going
to get your lavalier
if you plug in two
microphones, two separate mics.
CHRIS: Right.
So that's the
counterintuitive part.
If you have two
microphones set up,
you actually need to set
the camera to channel 1, not
channel 1 and 2.
AUDIENCE: If you have
a omnidirectional,
will it record down
in the left-hand side
of the [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: No.
DAVE: Yeah.
I've actually, I've
used that before.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS: Well, that's if
you have a stereo mic.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you have to have--
OK.
CHRIS: You have to have
a stereo mic, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But it can
plug into just channel--
you put it in channel 1 and
channel 2, one mic comes in,
and then it will
separate the tracks?
CHRIS: If you're recording
with a stereo mic,
you're going to
use both channels.
AUDIENCE: Oh, if you're
recording stereo.
OK.
DAVE: Sorry, I misunderstood.
CHRIS: Oh, yeah.
That's OK.
We do not have a
stereo microphone.
DAVE: Let's get to
our second microphone,
which is the lavalier.
If you guys look
in the camera kit,
you should see a box like this.
If you could just take
that out and open that up.
And this is kind
of tough to open,
but if you could take
this main little box out.
This is your lavalier battery.
And where it says push to
open, it's kind of tough,
but push that, and
the top should pop off
with a little help.
DENNIS: Could you turn
the top towards me?
DAVE: Yes, sorry.
[SNAPS]
This push button right
here, push it in.
And then pop-- actually,
it's hard to do--
and then pop the top off.
And that's where
the battery goes.
Some of them may have a
battery already in it.
Some of them may not.
Inside of the kit,
there is a AA battery.
Make sure that that is
placed into your transmitter.
And then close the top again,
or put the top back on.
AUDIENCE: Oh, can I
just jump [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE: I discouraged
jumping on it.
AUDIENCE: One last [INAUDIBLE].
I need to open this.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
Maybe--
AUDIENCE: Twist it.
DAVE: Oh, yeah.
You get it open?
Are you having trouble?
AUDIENCE: We got it.
DAVE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: We're just
trying to [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: Look at these.
The mark is definitely
not for fingers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you're right.
DAVE: On the bottoms, on
the side of the transmitter,
you'll see--
not the transmitter, just the--
CHRIS: Battery pack.
DAVE: --battery pack,
you'll see a switch
with three options-- off.
And the middle option
is a straight line.
And the third option
is a bent line.
The third option, which is
a bent line, is a filter.
And you don't want
to choose that.
You want to choose the middle
of the three options, which
is the straight line.
Make sure the switch is
on the middle of the three
options, the straight line.
Everybody there?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVE: Come on, guys.
I'll take that as a yes.
Now, also within your case, you
will see the actual lavalier
microphone with
the cord attached.
What you want to do is you want
to attach the end of the cord
into this silver jack right
here on your battery pack,
so right here.
And now is the fun part.
This is the clip that you use
to clip to somebody's shirt
or if they're wearing a tie.
Or I've even seen somebody
put these on hats.
But you want to use this
little pinch release right here
to open it up and slide
the lavalier into it.
And then you can
close it up again.
AUDIENCE: Ours is
a little different.
DAVE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Ours is
a little different.
DAVE: Oh, OK.
That's cool.
Everybody there?
And again, you should have a
little softy to put on the end.
So place that on top just
to protect your [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, that second XLR cable
that you had in your audio kit,
if you could take that out.
And once you have
that out, you're
going to connect one
end into this jack right
here on the battery
pack and the other end
into your second input on your
audio adapter in the camera.
And again, make sure
you hear it click.
Otherwise, you may not
have a clean connection.
DENNIS: Could you
put the cable in?
DAVE: Ah, sure.
Again, you put one end into the
battery pack and the other end
into your input
2 on your camera.
And again, make sure
you hear it click.
Now, if your battery
pack is switched
to the middle of the
three options, which
is a straight line,
if you guys want--
you already have
yours attached--
have one person be the subject.
So if you could just
clip it somewhere
on your shirts and the
other person monitor levels.
Now, the same thing you did
with the shotgun microphone.
CHRIS: So now, remember, if
you have both the shotgun
and the lav hooked
up at the same time,
you have to go to channel
1, that channel 1 input,
not channel 1 and 2.
DAVE: Otherwise, you're going
to be recording the same mic
in both channels, which is
your first one, which is that.
CHRIS: So I see most
of you-- all of you--
have two mics hooked up.
So everybody should be on
channel 1, that first switch.
DAVE: And again,
if you go to the P
menu, on the bottom right-hand
side of your LCD screen,
hit P Menu.
Go to your Audio Channel
2 Levels, that button.
And with the other person
speaking, adjust your levels.
AUDIENCE: Test.
AUDIENCE: Testing.
AUDIENCE: Test [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE: And again, your levels
should be hitting about 3/4
of the way up that
bar for channel 2.
[CHATTER]
All right, one last thing.
Just so both the camera
person and the audio person
can actually hear
what's being recorded,
we have a headphone
splitter in the case.
It should be, again, in
one of those front pockets.
And it looks like this.
Now, the bottom of the
camera on the front right,
you'll notice there's a
little panel you can open up--
bottom front right.
And there should be two jacks.
The bottom of the two, the green
one, is the headphone jack.
You want to plug the splitter
into that green jack.
And in case you
get lost some day
and you don't
remember which one is
the headphones, on the actual
cover to the two jacks,
on the bottom, you'll see a
little headphone symbol just
to let you know, in case,
just in case it ever
happens to you one day.
Now, in your camera case, you
have the lesser of the two
headphones, as far as quality.
The person operating
camera should be listening
through those headphones.
So whoever is operating camera,
take the lesser of the two
headphones, as far as quality.
In your audio bags, you
have nice headphones.
The person who is operating
boom should use these.
Because that person is the one
who should really know what's
going on in terms of sound.
Because he or she
needs to readjust
and should have the better of
the two sets of headphones.
CHRIS: One word about
those headphones--
those are wrapped in
a way that's not great
because the cables
get stretched.
So just a minor equipment note.
This is not the greatest
way to store them.
Because the cable stretches out.
So the best thing to do when
you put them back in the bag
is just to let the cable
fall kind of naturally.
One of the most frequent
issues that people
run into when they're
just starting out
is they solve an audio
problem by adjusting
the headphone
volume, which doesn't
solve the audio problem.
It makes you able
to hear it better,
but you're not affecting
your recording at all.
So Dave, why don't
you just quickly
go over the headphone volume
so you know where it is.
Because obviously, it
is important to have
a good volume in the headphones
so that you can actually
hear what's going on.
But it's not the approved way of
solving whatever the issue is.
DAVE: Within the P
menu at the top left,
you'll see the Menu button.
If you hit the Menu button--
you have to go into
the greater menu
rather than just rely
on the personal menu.
If you scroll down those
little icons on the left,
scroll down to the red toolbox.
Scroll down to the
red toolbox and hit
OK to enter the toolbox menu.
And once you're in the toolbox
menu, if you scroll down--
I think it's the third
choice from the top--
to Volume.
Normally, what you
want to do is--
well, first, once you
get to Volume, hit OK.
And I'd set that about
3/4 of the way up.
CHRIS: Generally, you're
going to set it and forget it.
You might want to
raise it if you're
in a bad situation in terms
of audio and you need to,
or lower it if you're
just getting blasted.
DAVE: But most importantly,
don't ever just blindly--
not blindly because it's
audio-- but don't just
go by what your ears
hear all the time.
Look at your levels first.
Always look at
your levels first.
If you have 3/4--
[STATIC]
Like you're.
Like you're
[STATIC, WORDS REPEATING]
CHRIS: Yeah, exactly.
That's the thing.
These mics are great,
but just the danger
is if you're not pointing
at what you want,
then you don't
get what you want.
But they're really,
really terrific
for situations like
this where there's
a lot of stuff going on in the
room or there's interference.
AUDIENCE: Now, why
does this sound--
it sounds so different than
it sounds without headsets on.
It doesn't sound real in
the-- it sounds very tinny.
CHRIS: So which sounds tinny?
When the headphones are on?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm not sure if it's
just like this mic
or if it's the combination.
CHRIS: It might be that.
What you might want to try--
AUDIENCE: Try unplugging.
CHRIS: Yeah, unplug one.
Just listen to one,
listen to the other.
AUDIENCE: Because it just--
I mean, it sounds good,
but it doesn't sound real.
It sounds like someone's
talking [? to a mic. ?]
CHRIS: Well, what it could be
is that if I'm over here talking
and that mic is picking
me up, too, that's
a long way away from me.
So that's going to
sound much more roomy.
There's a lot less--
it's not directional.
Check 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
So that sounds good?
AUDIENCE: It sounds good, but
it still doesn't sound real.
CHRIS: OK.
Let me hear what you mean.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It doesn't sound
like I hear now.
I'm not sure if it's
just my hearing.
CHRIS: Check 1, 2, 1, 2.
Well, that's because
it's mono audio.
And our ears are really good.
[CHUCKLES] But no, that's--
check 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8-- no, I mean it's--
AUDIENCE: It sounds like
a good, like, documentary.
CHRIS: Yeah, it's
actually overmodulating
when I talk loudly.
Hear that little-- here, you--
so when I go check
1, 2, 3, 4, you
hear that little bzzt,
bzzt, bzzt, in my voice?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHRIS: That Is overmodulation,
which is that it's too loud.
So what you want to
do there is fix either
by going into the camera
menu and reducing the level
or going back further.
AUDIENCE: So how
much further back?
CHRIS: Check 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
AUDIENCE: I guess
you do sound more--
I mean, I sound funny.
CHRIS: Yeah, right, exactly.
So that's a really big, big
issue in audio recording.
If you get that clipping,
that bzzt, bzzt, bzzt, bzzt,
you can't fix it.
It's just that's the way it is.
So there's nothing you
can do in post-production.
So that's a really crucial
thing to know about.
And that's also what will happen
if you set it to the plus 48
volts that Dave
was talking about.
Because then, you're basically
getting too much signal
into the camera.
And you're going to get
that distortion, as well.
So you want to make sure that--
the two things, the
two worst things,
that can happen are that
kind of overmodulation,
that distortion, and if the
level is so low that you don't
hear me at all
and the background
just comes up really loudly.
So if you're down at
like minus 30, minus 24,
you can bring it up in editing.
You can make the level good.
But everything else
comes up along with it.
So then the room--
AUDIENCE: Sounds very staticky.
CHRIS: Exactly.
And then the other bad
thing is if I'm too loud.
So it's like not too
loud, not too soft.
Just get it right in the
middle in terms of the level.
And again, listen with
your ears for problems
like overmodulation,
interference, background
interference-- trucks,
other people talking.
If you wanted to do
an interview with me,
this is a really typical
situation in a documentary.
You come in, and you're doing
a documentary on this class.
And you say, hey, can you say
a few words about the class?
And I go, OK, let's
do it right now.
They're all talking over there.
There's a lot of stuff going on.
But if I talk to you like this
and you use that microphone,
you're still going to get
a good level from me, even
despite the fact
that they're talking.
If you put a lavalier on me
and I'm standing, especially
even closer there, Dave talking,
them talking, all of that gets
picked up at the
same level as me.
And all of a sudden,
you can't pick it out.
You can't distinguish it.
And it becomes really
frustrating and difficult
in post-production.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
CHRIS: So that's why this
is a great microphone
to have for documentary,
as long as somebody
is operating it and paying
attention and listening.
Not great if you just run into a
room, throw it down on a table,
or just prop it up
somewhere and then go.
Because everything outside the
field doesn't get picked up.
So there you go.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS: So anyway, so here's
the plan for next week.
The assignment, the first
production assignment,
is to shoot a scene in groups.
And I think what we're going to
do is just, for the beginning,
since we're all kind
of new in this class,
we're assigning groups.
But in the future,
you can, of course,
work with whomever you choose
or alone, in many cases.
But I think we'll just go with
the three groups we have here--
1, 2, 3.
So each of you can work
in these three teams
that we have set up right now.
And the assignment
is to shoot a scene.
And there's very, very wide
latitude in what that means.
It could be a documentary
scene of someone
making dinner and explaining
what they're doing, how they're
making their pasta, with insert
shots of the cooking that's
happening and close-ups
of the person talking
and wide shots that
establish the space, which
would be a classic thing.
It could be something
in the lab if you
want to do something
science-related.
It could be a fiction scene.
If you want to have a couple
of friends be your actors,
you can write or improvise
something and film that.
The requirements
are fairly simple.
We want you to use sound.
So we want you to
record sound and video
at the same time, which
is why you're going
to be working in teams of two.
And we also want you to
shoot more than one shot.
So don't just do
one hand-held shot
following somebody
around and talking.
And the reason for
that is that we're
going to use this
material in our lab
next week when we do our
introduction to editing.
So right now, all you have
to do is shoot a scene.
As I said, it could
be very simple,
something you can shoot
in an hour or two,
so as simple or as
ambitious as you want.
You'll turn in the tape
next week, next Wednesday
night, at the lecture.
And we'll have it ready for
you to edit on Friday morning
in the lab.